[Music]
foreign
[Music]
have you ever wondered why organizations
of all sizes are rapidly migrating to
the cloud and what steps they are taking
in order to maximize their chances of
success hi I'm Mike Coleman a developer
advocate here at Google cloud and I'm
joined today by one of our engineering
managers joa Reich in this video we're
going to talk about how organizations
can get started with the cloud we'll
cover why organizations are moving to
the cloud and some of the challenges
associated with that move then we'll
talk about common Cloud adoption
patterns and finally we'll look at how
to accelerate your move to the cloud by
migrating some of your existing
applications
let's start with the Y joov what
benefits are customers receiving from
moving to Google Cloud today
there are a lot of benefits to moving to
the cloud but I wanted to specifically
talk about three different ones
the first is around flexibility with
Cloud it's very easy for customers to
experiment and find the right solution
to their unique challenges
for instance when you look at where you
can run your workloads you can run on
VMS or containers and for containers you
have the choice to running on a
serverless platform like Cloud run fully
managed kubernetes with Google
kubernetes engine in autopilot mode or a
more traditional kubernetes cluster with
GK in standard mode next there is an
idea of cost saving which manifests
itself in a couple of different ways
first you only pay for what you use you
don't need to invest in purchasing
physical Hardware that is only used
intermittently which leads me to the
second Point around cost or more
specifically opportunity cost for
instance let's say you want to run a
proof of concept for a new service you
might want to offer with physical
Hardware it can be very risky to
experiment because you have to make a
large Financial investment up front in
order to acquire the hardware
whereas with the cloud you can spin up a
few instances run your POC and spin them
down when you're finished there is much
less Financial Risk in that second model
plus it takes a lot of time to get that
stuff deployed right
exactly you need to order the hardware
make sure you have the data center space
and then get it actually installed it's
a lot of money and a lot of waiting and
if the experiment doesn't pen off that
can be problematic however with Cloud as
I mentioned you can spin up resources in
a matter of minutes and you only pay for
what you use so it's minimal risk and
allows you to move much faster
finally let's talk about reliability
with the Google Cloud we operate to a
large extent as your site reliability
Engineers we handle a lot of the
management of the underlying
infrastructure as well as ensuring it's
secured in the case of serverless
platforms we do virtually all that work
for you and with other platform we take
care of a big chunk of it the bottom
line is that it's less work for you and
the less to worry about allow you to
focus on your business issues
while there are significant benefits to
moving to the cloud there are also some
key challenges that potential adopters
should be aware of one thing I've
personally done a few times is
underestimate the complexity at first
glance
a move to the cloud involves many
different teams and various deeply
connected systems and invariably as you
dig in you're going to find things you
initially missed
you're also going to have to deal with
inertia change is scary for a lot of
people and that fear can sometimes
manifest itself in people being
resistant to new technologies and
processes additionally we can get caught
up in the hole if it ain't broke don't
fix it mentality where we see good
enough as being the desired end state
yo of what other challenges have you
seen
you mentioned the complexity of existing
systems but it's also important to
recognize that people can be overwhelmed
by the sheer number of choices when it
comes to cloud-based software and
services learning how to best leverage
all of these choices will require
operators to develop new skills which
while potentially a challenge it's also
a benefit it's rarely a bad thing to add
new tools to your toolbox
the other Big Challenge we all need to
be cognizant of is setting appropriate
expectations the journey to the cloud
needs to be done in a measured manner we
need to pick early project that maximize
our chances for Success which means
tempering expectations in some overnight
miracle certainly you can Notch some
early wins but the full benefits of the
cloud are realized over a big period of
time
we've talked about the benefits and
challenges of moving to the cloud so I
think it makes sense at this point to
discuss what makes a good migration
project
first and foremost start with a business
objective why are you moving to the
cloud
because as we discussed it takes a
degree of work and planning
from a technical perspective it's
important to step back and take a
platform view don't get too focused on
any one application or system but rather
how it all comes together this means you
should stay rooted in some key areas
where you have good familiarity but push
the envelope where it makes sense don't
try to bowl the ocean
totally agree on those points and would
add that one size does not fit all use a
mix of approaches this is especially
important when you think about how you
start your Cloud Journey
what's the answer to the question how do
I get something actually running in the
cloud
as we've said before there is no one way
that is correct and we could do a video
series just discussing the intricacies
of different adoption patterns for the
sake of brevity let's just focus on a
few here
maybe the easiest way to get a workload
into the cloud is what is often called
lift and shift the idea of taking
something running in your data center
likely in a VM and moving that workload
as is into the cloud so for VMS that's
taking an application off a server
running on-prem and putting it into a
Google compute engine instance in some
cases you can go a level deeper for
instance if you're running a mySQL
database in a VM you might actually
choose to move that to a managed service
like Cloud SQL rather than onto a
generic VM with mySQL installed
the next pattern is kind of an extension
of the first which is where you
selectively refactor an application you
might migrate a monolithic application
into a GCE instance and then decide to
start breaking it into distinct Parts
you take the database and move it to
Cloud SQL then you break out a service
maybe it's the payment processing
service and you run that in its own
container then you break out the
authentication Service into its own
container some stuff may stay in the VM
and other stuff is running in containers
but all those Services can still
communicate
the final major bucket is where you
actually decide it's better to Simply
rebuild your application from scratch in
the cloud leveraging cloud native
Technologies and design patterns while
this approach may take a bit longer than
the others it often results in the
ability to integrate new functionality
as well as derive the most value from
the cloud
so if we look at a couple of things we
just said there are a couple of
different areas of consideration for
customers when they think of deploying
their first workloads to Google Cloud
the first area is answering the question
what applications are best suited for me
to move in a lot of cases migrating
existing workloads is going to be easier
than developing an application from
scratch whether that's a brand new
application or a rewrite of an existing
application but even if it's easier to
lift and shift an existing application
you should still need to figure out what
application have the highest Target for
Success the second area is deciding how
that application is going to run in
Google Cloud are you just going to
migrate them from an on-prem VM to a GC
instance do we want to containerize that
application if you containerize it
should you run it on cloud run or gke
the answer to these questions are going
to be a combination of what makes sense
for your business and what is
technically feasible fortunately Google
cloud has some tooling that can help
with assessing the technical feasibility
of migrating existing VM based workloads
to Google Cloud for starters we have the
migration fit assessment tool or mfit
for short yoav I think since your team
actually builds mfit maybe you want to
describe what it does mfit can assess VM
based applications and determine both
what a suitable Target for the
application is as well as any work that
might need to be done in order to
migrate that application essentially we
give a score that indicates the
likelihood of success and the effort
involved in it because we know customers
have hundreds and sometimes thousands of
applications they want to assess
and fit integrates with VMware vsphere
it can examine a given vsphere server
figure out what workers are on the
system at the VM level for instance what
OS is running how much RAM is installed
Etc this helps give a first pass at
determining which VMS might be a
suitable candidate for migration
for a more granular look and fit can
collect data from inside the VM to give
a report on what services and
applications are actually running
on with this information you can begin
to put together a plan on which
applications to migrate
for the actual migration step we have a
host of different migration tooling for
compute we have migrate for compute
engine as well as migrate to containers
and for databases we have database
migration Services you can learn more
about those products via a bunch of
different videos here on YouTube as well
as the documentation which we'll Link in
the description
that's about all the time we have today
thanks for watching be sure to check out
those other videos as well as the
documentation I mentioned to learn about
how Google Cloud can help ease your move
to the cloud and of course don't forget
to like And subscribe so you'll be
notified whenever we publish new content
foreign
[Music]